when we think of Greek mythology's most
iconic stories and figures outside of
its gods and goddesses there are plenty
of heroes that come to mind from
Odysseus and his epic voyage home to
Heracles and his 12 labors and that's
all even mentioned in the likes of
Theseus Achilles Jason and of course
Perseus perhaps Greek mythology's most
celebrated hero there are however some
heroes who never really get a share of
the spotlight despite having their own
epic stories and I think the rise and
fall of Bellerophon is a perfect example
Bellerophon or Bellerophon tez is often
described as the son of Poseidon and yer
enemy the wife of Glaucus king of
Corinth there are however some poets who
disagreed believe in that Glaucus was
actually his father and though Glaucus
his mother was a daughter of the Titan
atlas given him some kind of divinity I
personally like to look at Bellerophon
as the demigod son of Poseidon his story
begins with him being exiled from his
home in Argos
he stood before King praetor's having
committed the crime of murder who
exactly he killed is never really
discussed in any detail it can vary from
his own brother to a shadowy enemy and
even a ruler of the Corinthians we don't
know for certain who he killed and the
reasons why we just know that he
committed the crime of murder for some
unknown reason King praetor's cleanse
Bellerophon of his crime and gave him a
royal pardon the King's wife Queenston
aboah took a liking to Bellerophon and
when her advances were rejected she
accused him of forcing himself upon her
the King believed in the word of his
wife was now furious to say the least
not only had Bellerophon taken his
hospitality and thrown it back in his
face but the pardon he gave him now made
him a guest in his kingdom and to kill a
guest in your own kingdom is to incur
the wrath of Zeus the only solution
praetors had was to send Bellerophon to
his father-in-law King II a patís
accompanied of a sealed letter asking
him to execute Bellerophon for violating
his wife when he arrived in lycée he
dined of the king for several days
before he read the message and even then
the epitome self feared the Iranians
would descend upon him for murder
a guest so instead he sent Bellerophon
on a mission that he believed to be
impossible he sent him to slay the
Chimera a fire-breathing hybrid monster
with the head and body of a goat and
lion and a serpent for a tail
the Chimera had plagued the countryside
of lycée affort felt like an eternity
and if it did indeed kill Bellerophon
then his death would no longer be at the
hands of eeeh patties or praetor's if by
some means he managed to slay the
Chimera the nia Bertie's would have been
seen as the hero king who saved his
people he could see no downside to his
plan now at this point in time
Bellerophon wasn't an established hero
who you will expect to just walk up to
the Chimera shop of its multiple heads
and still head home in time for happy
hour of Dionysus know he would need help
and a lot of it he first traveled to the
renowned seer Paulo HEDIS who gave him
crucial advice about his upcoming battle
of the Chimera
he told Bellerophon that he would have
to obtain the services of the winged
steed Pegasus which would give him a
distinct advantage in battle this ties
in to the more classical depictions of
the Chimera or it didn't have wings
meaning flying above the beasts would
help prevent him from being torn to
pieces and burnt to cinders
Pegasus however would not come quietly
he would have to be tamed and in order
to do this he would have to spend the
evening in the temple of Athena in
during his time in the temple with ena
appeared to him in a dream and when he
awoke he was given a golden bridle that
he would use to tame Pegasus in some
accounts Athena
appeared to him with Pegasus and in
others he would have to take the bridle
and find the horse himself
there are even versions where it was
Poseidon who appeared to him and with
Poseidon being the god of horses he then
presented Pegasus to his son Bellerophon
at this point unaware of his father's
true identity with the aid of Pegasus
Bellerophon arrived in life seer ready
to face the Chimera it didn't take long
however for Bellerophon to realize that
the volley of arrows that he rained down
had
effect and so he was left flying around
aimlessly attempting to avoid the turret
of fire being expelled by the chimera
eventually the fire gave him an idea on
the end of his spear he attached a large
block of lead he then approached the
Camaro of his spear pointed head-on
the Chimera continued to breathe fire
but this time the lead began to melt
causing the block of lead to break off
and fall into the chimeras throat where
it lodged itself the lead continued to
melt and burn the Chimera from the
inside blocking its air passage and
causing it to suffocate all of a sudden
Bellerophon had done the impossible he
had slain the Chimera upon return in the
king was shocked but despite his heroics
the abbot EES had taken all of the
credit and he refused to acknowledge
that it was Bellerophon who had in fact
slain the Chimera instead he sent him on
another quest in order to prove himself
he was sent to quell the uprising of the
Amazons and the salami tribes of
warriors who had not accepted
yepp ities as their king flying high
above them on Pegasus
he would then drop boulders on them down
below literally squashing the rebellion
the Alberti's was now sure that
Bellerophon could not have been a mere
mortal and fear in him now more than
ever he decided to have him assassinated
the last task he was given was to find a
group of pirates who had stolen from the
crown and it was during this encounter
that the assassins would strike sadly
for the King he had waited too long and
now Bellerophon was now more than aware
of his strength and divine nature upon
being ambushed he then killed all of the
assassins that were sent after him
yepp ities then sent his palace goons to
finish the job but Bellerophon looked to
his father for assistance and Poseidon
did indeed answer the flood in parts of
the city when the guards approached him
I've no one to turn to yeah Betty's
finally conceded and presented
Bellerophon of a new sealed letter
stating that he would marry his youngest
daughter and be given half of the
kingdom
Bellerophon was now given the
recognition that he felt he deserved as
well as riches beyond his wildest dreams
he was now Bellerophon tez the slayer of
monsters the man who saved Lai SIA
however even a fairly exciting human
life now seemed mundane he had defeated
the Chimera after all and proven himself
he felt he now belonged on Mount Olympus
he's rightful home eventually he was so
overcome with boredom he took Pegasus
and began his ascent to Olympus Zeus
watching from above took his actions as
an insult
Zeus would then send a gadfly to sting
Pegasus causing him to bark and better
off on to be thrown off falling back
down to earth where he belonged pegasus
eventually recovered and continued his
journey to Olympus where he will be
greeted and welcomed by Zeus he was then
given the job of carrying Zeus's
Thunderbolts across the sky Bellerophon
however did not share the same faint in
some stories The Fool down to earth
killed him which in this case oddly
enough seems to be the happy ending in
other stories the four merely crippled
him leaving him barely able to walk he
was cursed to roam the earth for
eternity a shell of the man that he used
to be hated by both mortals and gods
alike
he was no longer the Slayer of monsters
he was Bellerophon than nobody the
living example of what happened to those
who let their hubris dictate their
actions and the great hero that once was
was no longer the tales of Bellerophon
arguably paved the way for many of the
Greek heroes that followed the story of
Heracles performing labors to earn his
Redemption is honestly very similar if
not the exact same as paraffins journey
as the years past tales of Bellerophon
was slowly phased out and replaced by
the likes of Perseus many of us today
when we think of a hero right in Pegasus
will immediately think of Perseus and
it's this fade in memory of a once great
hero that makes better off on a tragic
hero
everybody seems to enjoy a good rise and
fall story but I think the reason I
enjoy better reform story is because of
how human it is the gods and goddesses
are often presented as flawed and the
heroes of Greek mythology are really no
different it's quite an easy story to
relate to obviously not in terms of
flying around on the horse killing
monsters and dropping boulders on people
but in terms of how we handle Fame and
success the story serves as a reminder
to the importance of humbleness and
humility not being overcome by our own
arrogance almost the idea of knowing
your capabilities and place in society
but then again like Bellerophon we
should always be challenged in these
things you never really know your limits
capabilities and even your place in
society until you challenge them
regardless of the outcome is positive or
negative we can make mistakes and even
do bad things and choose to learn from
them and ultimately better ourselves
unlike Bellerophon we can start off with
good intentions and end up losing
ourselves and that is when you fall the
hardest if you have any thoughts on
Bellerophon story that you like to share
then feel free to do so in the comments
below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained reminding you that
Bellerophon is one of the main stories
of our book so by the book if you want
otherwise Bellerophon might just drop a
ball in your head I'm sailing on you
[Music]